this right here is a picture of Carl
Linnaeus and I'm sure I'm mispronouncing
the word and he's a Swedish gentleman
who lived in the 1700s and he's known as
the father of modern taxonomy and the
word taxonomy if you just split it up
into its original root it really is the
science of really classifying things but
when people talk about taxonomy in this
particular in Carl Linnaeus case they're
talking about the classification of
living things so classifying classifying
organisms and his real innovation before
he came about people realized that you
had species of animals that Lions had
certain properties that made them all
Lions that they could interbreed and
things like that that monkey or
chimpanzees would all interbreed and
that would be a separate species and
that polar bears were separate species
and that humans were a separate species
but what he really brought to the table
is he decided well let me just not just
group animals into species maybe I can
group species into into other categories
and that's where we get the genus from
you group similar species into a genus
and then he went even beyond that
because even the idea of grouping things
into a genus would dated back to the
ancient Greeks he said well why don't I
group similar Genesis together into
orders orders together into classes and
then classes together into kingdoms
so really what he did is he said well
maybe I can classify I can create a tree
I can create a tree of life I can create
a structure so we can really see how far
apart any two organisms are and so
that's why he's really the father of
modern taxonomy and he did not have many
tools all he could do is look at the
power and his powers of observation says
ok those kind of animals they have fur
or they reproduce in this way or they
lay eggs or they don't lay eggs or they
have spinal columns or they don't have
spinal columns so that's the best that
he could do when he did his taxonomy but
since then there's obviously been tons
of innovations and how we perceive
animals or the natural world and our
tools for studying them so one thing
that he did not know about is evolution
this idea of common intra common
ancestry and between our understandings
of evolution and our ability to look
back at the fossil record that helps us
get more precise at figuring out which
animals are related to which we can see
do they have a common ancestor more
recent
or further back and what even Charles
Darwin didn't have which we now use as a
tool in taxonomy is that it is the
genetic evidence so now we don't even
have to rely on the fossil record we can
look at the DNA of two species that
exist today and see how similar are
though is that DNA and that tells us how
recently they branched apart if we were
able to find it in the fossil record or
how recently in the past did these two
species become two different species now
with that said I do want to make this
clear and this is something that you
know I've always had a little bit was
fuzzy for me the first time that I was
exposed to this idea of taxonomy is that
taxonomy is as much an art as it's a
science and today even to this day
people are debating about the best way
to classify things and how what do you
pay attention to and DNA has been the
best tool so far and giving us a more
systematic a more analytical way of
deciding how close to animals are but to
a large degree a lot of these categories
the deciding we're divided along kingdom
phylum class order family tribe these
are somewhat arbitrary these are just
picked based on early taxonomists
including Carl Linnaeus and saying oh
this looks like a grouping right over
here but they could have grouped at a
broader level or a deeper level so these
things right over here are somewhat
arbitrary a more analytical way just to
see how much DNA you have in common and
then use that as a measure of how far
apart two animals are or really I should
say two species are because this
taxonomy doesn't even apply just to
animals it applies to plants and
bacteria and and archaea and all sorts
of things so it's actually a broader
thing than just animals now with that
out of the way what I thought would be
fun just so that we could really get a
sense of where modern taxonomy is where
the field that was essentially fathered
by Carl Linnaeus where it is now how we
and and use that to figure out where we
humans fit into the big picture and
obviously I'm drawing just a small
fraction of the universe of the
organisms that we even know about right
now but at least it frames the picture
in terms of something we understand in
particular us in particular humans now
our species we call ourselves humans but
we're really Homo sapiens and the
sapiens is the species part
and then homo is the genus and what I'm
doing right over here is I'm saying well
if the home was the genus what other
what other species were inside of homo
and the reality is or at least as far as
we know there are no other living
species inside inside of homo that we we
probably killed them all off or did or
maybe we interpreted with them somehow
which might have argued that maybe they
weren't different species but more
likely they were competing in the same
ecosystems and they became injured
endangered species very quickly when
they competed with our ancestors but the
most recent other species within the
genus that we know about are the
Neanderthals and the formal were the
formal the formal term for their species
is neanderthalensis now if we go further
up the tree of life further up to the
taxonomy and you'll sometimes see tribe
mentions sometimes you won't and we tend
to get a little bit more granular the
closer we get to humans when we go
further away in the Tree of Life we get
a little bit less granular sometimes but
that's not always the case as well you
go a little bit further up then you get
to home it home and Nene and I'm sure
I'm mispronouncing some of this as well
but the other another species that's in
homo nene
that is not in homo and I'm definitely
not listing all of them and that's why
I'm showing all of these other branches
all of these other branches over here is
what we call the common chimpanzee and
their species name is there there's
their genus is pan and their species is
troglodytes so you would refer to them
as Pan troglodytes and that's also
another convention that Carl Linnaeus
came up with is that you refer to a
particular species by its genus and then
its species and you capitalize the genus
and you lowercase a species so we're
Homo sapiens this is Homo
neanderthalensis this is Pan troglodytes
or often referred to as chimpanzees now
if you go up one one higher level of
broadness on this tree of life you then
get to the family and we are in the
family home in a day and hominid day and
I'm sure I'm mispronouncing it once
again but just to give you an example so
everything I've listed so far everything
I've talked about so far are within this
family and to show you an animal that is
not in this family you just have to look
at the gorillas and you could call it
the gorilla knee the gorilla knee
Gorrell any gorilla or G gorilla
that's that's its actual species name
and this family right over here
sometimes the common term is the great
apes the great apes
now you go one further level and this is
the whole reason why I'm doing this and
I'm not by any means am I being
exhaustive about the other other species
that are in that family but that are not
in our tribe I'm just trying to give you
a picture of as we get further and
further out as we get further out of our
tribe our family our order we're getting
to things where the common ancestry with
human goes further and further back in
time the genetic similarities become
more and more different and even just
the physical differences if we look at
it at a very superficial level become
more and more and more different so you
get to even a broader category this is
where you get to the primates and this
is probably something that you might be
somewhat familiar from with and the term
primates is general these animals that
look like they either live in trees or
rain forests or their descendant of
things that live in trees so they have
these things that they can grasp things
with they're good at climbing broadly
not all of them are humans are probably
the worst primates when it comes to
climbing or one of the worse but that's
the general classification that we
that's what we generally think of when
we think of primates and if we think of
a primate that is not a great ape you
just have to think of a baboon so this
right here is a baboon it is a primate
but it is not a great ape it is probably
a descendant some baboons do actually
don't live in trees but all of them are
probably descended from things that
first live in trees and that's why their
hands and their feet look the way they
do now you get to even a broader level
of classification you get to the mammals
and once again probably something you're
used to thinking about mammals are
air-breathing animals and they tend to
have fur or hair they tend to they tend
to provide some form of milk for their
young they have active mammary glands
there's other things that we can talk
about what makes a mammal I'm not going
to go to the rigorous definition but
just to give you an example of a mammal
that is not a primate I could I could
show you this polar bear right over here
this is a mammal mammal that is not a
mammal that is not a primate and I can
do other things I could show you a tiger
or I could show you a a giraffe or a
horse and so I'm by no stretch of the
imagination
am I being comprehensive but let's keep
getting broader now let's go now let's
go to the class or where we're already
at the class of Mammalia now let's go to
the phylum and phylum we are humans and
all mammals we are in the phylum
chordates and chordates chordates we're
actually we're actually within the sub
phylum which I didn't write here
vertebrates which means we have a
vertebra we have a spinal column with a
spinal cord in it coordinates are a
little bit more general chordates is a
phylum we're kind of the arrangement of
where the mouth is where the digestive
organs where the anus is where the where
the spinal column is where the brains
where the eyes where the mouth they're
kind of all in the same place and if you
think about it everything I've listed
here kind of has the same general
structure you have a spinal column you
have a brain you have a mouth then the
mouth leaves to some type of a digestive
column and at the end of it you have an
anus over there and you have eyes in
front of the brain and so this is a
general way and I'm not being very
rigorous here is how you describe a
chordate and to show a chordate that is
not a mammal you would just have to
think of fish or sharks so this right
over here this right over here let me
make sure let me this right over here is
a is a non mammal cordate this is a
great white shark over here now let's go
even broader and you'll see now we're
getting to things that are very very not
very very not a human like so you go one
step for broader now we're in Animalia
where the kingdom of animals and this is
the broadest definition that or the
broadest category that carlin a is
thought about well actually he did go
into the into trees as well but when you
think of a kingdom animals and you think
of things that aren't chordates you
start going into things like insects and
you start going into things like
jellyfish if you go even broader now
we're talking about the domain you go to
Eukarya so these are all organisms that
have cells and inside those cells they
have complex structures so if you fear
you carry you have cells with complex
structures if you're a pro carrier which
you don't have complex structures inside
your cell but other Eukarya that are not
animals include things like include
things like like plants and obviously
I'm giving no justice to this whole
branch of the Tree of Life I can it
could be just as rich or richer than
everything I've drawn over
this is just a small fraction of the
entire Tree of Life
but let's go even broader than that so
if you go even broader than that and you
say well what's a kind of life-form that
isn't eukaryote that wouldn't have these
more complex cell structures these the
mitochondria in the cells the the the
cell nucleus is then you just have to
think about something like bacteria and
if you want to go even broader there's
things like viruses that you can even
debate whether they really even are life
because they're dependent on other
life-forms for X with their actual
reproduction but they are they do have
genetic material like everything else
and that to me is kind of a mind-blowing
idea as different as a plant is look it
up house plant is in your house right
now or the tree when you walk home or
bacteria or this jellyfish there is a
commonality that we all have DNA and
that DNA for the most part replicates in
a very very very similar way so it's
actually crazy that we actually even are
related that we even do have a common
ancestor with some of these things and
then it even begs the question well what
about things like viruses anyway I'll
leave you here and I really just want
you to let you know that kind of make
sure you realize that this is a a it's
definitely worth studying because we we
understand where we fit in and kind of
the universe of living things but I also
want to let you know that it is a little
bit of an art on where you decide where
to make these classifications where you
decide to focus on whether you want to
focus on you know what properties
whether is how they reproduce or how
they feed their young or can they move
around or what they breathe or whatever
things like that anyway I'll let you go
there